في جميع أنحاء الولايات المتحدة ، يتزايد الطلب على علاج الصحة العقلية
،
ويكافح الناس لمعرفة من أين يبدأ
نوع مقدمي الخدمات الموجودين وما هو
نوع الخدمات الموجودة وكيف يمكنك
البحث عن واحدة
تقول رابطة كليات الطب الأمريكية إنها
ليست كافية تقريبًا  مقدمو خدمات الصحة العقلية
لتلبية الطلب
المتزايد على عدد السكان في البلاد
أظهر تحليل أجري في 2018 أن القوة العاملة
للأطباء النفسيين تتقلص ويمكن أن
تنخفض إلى أدنى مستوى متوقع يصل إلى
31000 طبيب نفسي في غضون عامين فقط ، لذا
إذا كنت تكافح من أجل الحصول على
موعد  مع طبيب نفسي أو
معالج نفسي مرخص له جودي
بومشتاين يقول لا تقيد بحثك عن
العاملين الاجتماعيين الإكلينيكيين
المرخصين المرخصين للمستشارين المهنيين المرخصين
للزواج والمعالجين الأسريين
الذين يمكنهم جميعًا تقديم نفس النوع من
العلاج للعثور على معالج
محتمل يقترح بومشتاين سحب الأدلة عبر الإنترنت
التي  قائمة مقدمي الخدمة في
منطقتك قد يقدم بعض أصحاب العمل تعليمات مجانية
على المدى القصير
تتحقق مزايا الفوائد الصحية من مقدمي الخدمات من القطاع الخاص بشأن
ما إذا كان لديهم متدربون إكلينيكيون
يمكنهم المساعدة إذا كنت
تتعامل مع شركة تأمين وتراجع الخيارات
معهم ، فقد يعوضونك عن
جزء من التكلفة لرؤية شبكة
خارج الشبكة  يتحدث مزود
الرعاية إلى مقدم الرعاية الأولية الخاص بك أيضًا أو
يقول طبيب الأطفال الخاص بطفلك بومشتاين إنه
قد يكون لديهم نظرة على الأطباء في
مجتمعك ويمكنهم إحالتك ، كما يمكنك
التحدث إلى مدرسة طفلك ، وقد تكون
هناك مساعدة متاحة هناك أخيرًا إذا
لم تتمكن من الحصول على موعد  على الفور احصل
على قائمة انتظار لحظة الصحة أنا
ماندي غايثر